- Hi, I'm Maxley, and I'm nine years old.
(dramatic music)
Today, two chefs are going to compete
to make my dream Pokemon dish.
(cartoon attack sounds)
(playful music)
- What's up?
- Hi.
- I'm Owen. Nice to meet you.
- Hi, I'm Maxley.
- I'm H.
- I'm a food content creator
based out of Los Angeles
and I specialize in sandwiches.
I'm so pumped to be on this
competition and even more pumped
to be cooking alongside
my dear friend, H Woo Lee.
So if you were a Pokemon,
what would you eat?
- [Maxley] Hmm... first,
we got the berries.
- [Owen] So yellow berries?
- Yep.
- Are the Pokemon super hungry today?
- Probably. They haven't even eaten.
- I am a food content creator,
and this is my first time
on "I Draw, You Cook".
I feel like, especially with Owen,
it's not really a competition.
It's just for fun.
I will still win.
- [Maxley] Now, we need the cake.
- [Owen] So these are layers, right?
- Yes, they are layers.
- [Owen] Okay, and now what is that?
- [Maxley] It's just
the markings and stuff.
- Do you like sweets?
- Oh yeah. A little.
- Little hesitant there.
So you more savory or... little of both?
- In the middle. A little bit of both.
- Do you have a favorite fruit?
- Fruit? Fruit, banana.
- Okay, so banana's your favorite?
- Yes. This cake was supposed
to be given by Arceus.
- So it's a revive for all the Pokemon.
- It's kind of like that
'cause there's no...
- Like a full restore?
- Yeah, it's kind of like a full restore.
- Yeah.
I feel like he and I are connecting
on some level of Pokemon.
I got some of the references.
- So do you have a favorite food?
- Loco Moco.
- Loco Moco!
- Okay.
- It's Hawaiian food.
- What are your other
types of favorite foods?
- Chicken cutlet.
- You have a favorite kind of sushi?
- Oh, yeah. California roll.
- What's your favorite vegetable?
- Broccoli.
- [Owen] All right. So
what is this blue thing?
- It's called ocean mist.
- To quench the thirst of the Pokemon?
- Yes.
- [Owen] I mean, yeah, like
he's eating a cake this big.
He needs a lot of liquid.
- You are correct.
- I'm kind of a little nervous
just because there's
so many colors going on
and immediately I'm seeing a very big cake
and I don't bake whatsoever.
All right, so we got some
star action going here.
- [Maxley] Yep.
- [Owen] So what is that for?
- Well, they eat it like
regular food, like the cake.
- So do you think we can
actually make this Pokemon dish
into what you want?
- Yeah, I think so.
Good luck to both of you.
(high fives)
(cartoon blast)
(giggles)
(upbeat music)
- I'm gonna start with a
tiered banana bread cake,
because Max's favorite fruit is banana.
- I am making sushi rice
for the first layer of cake
which is gonna be layered
with other components
of Max's favorite food,
Loco Moco.
- Ah.
I'm very worried.
I was also thinking of making a Loco Moco.
I thought it was great idea.
It hits right on the spot of
what his favorite food is.
- You start with sushi grain rice.
I will start it and then get
onto my next layer of the cake,
the chicken cutlet layer of the cake.
- That's not in a normal Loco Moco, okay?
- If you'll remember,
- [H] I don't-
- he said his other favorite
food was chicken cutlet.
- Ooo, that's true.
- So I'm adding all those favorite foods.
- Is this your mom's recipe?
- It is.
- Dammit.
- It's really good.
- She makes a really good banana bread.
- Truthfully, I never make
sweets except for ice cream.
But...
(Owen pounds the meat pounder)
Do you wanna wait? (chuckles)
- No, I don't.
- Okay.
(meat pounder hitting the cutting board)
This is my impression of how Owen cooks.
(making sound affects of
loud cooking utensils)
(meat pounder banging on the table)
But for this time, I would like
to make a banana bread cake.
- I feel like I cook pretty fast.
I get the job done.
It's very free flowing.
- He's loud and big and that's reflective
of his personality as well.
I gotta be honest, I'm like really bad
at one hand cracking eggs.
- I'm pretty good at it.
I know pretty much every way
there is to crack an egg.
So you take one egg, you take another egg
and you crack the egg on the other egg.
Look at that.
Have a little fun with it.
You know, crack the
eggs against each other.
(eggs crack, both laugh)
Hey!
- Perfect! It works.
- Do two hands. Watch this.
(eggs crack)
Boom.
- (laughing) What the?
Whisk the eggs thoroughly.
Baking soda, salt, white sugar,
brown sugar, vanilla paste,
canola oil, buttermilk
secret ingredient, wet batter, dry batter.
Combine it all together.
(whisk taps the glass)
I'm just gonna kind of fold it in.
So once you don't really see
too many clumps of flour,
then you can start pouring it
into your pre-greased cake molds.
Then we'll bake these off.
- Have you cooked for kids a lot?
- No. You?
- No, but I consider myself a kid
and I cook for myself every day.
- Got it.
- So yes.
- So now we're gonna shallow fry.
You want to drop it away.
- You're looking for a nice golden brown.
And then you're gonna flip it.
Three to five minutes per side.
- So for the next part of the drawing,
these five little star boys
are gonna be star shaped chicken nuggets.
- I love chicken nuggets.
- Season our ground chicken with paprika,
some onion powder, garlic
powder, black pepper,
and some salt.
(hot oil sizzling)
- We got a nice golden brown
and we're just gonna set that aside.
Let a rest, season it.
Thank you chef.
- Of course.
- Now we're gonna get started
on the Loco Moco beef patty.
- Okay, so we're gonna
crack two eggs in here.
Mix it all together.
You've got your wonderful mixture
and bang, (mixture plops
onto parchment paper)
flatten it out.
- So we got ground beef, chopped up onion,
two eggs, panco, garlic,
oyster sauce, worcestershire.
Feel like that was pretty good.
- It was pretty good.
- Really bind the ingredients together.
We're gonna take this ring
mold and shape the meat.
Once we have it nice and
compact in its perfect circle,
we're gonna go bake it.
- This is looking good.
- You think that looks good?
There's just a layer of chicken sludge.
(playful music)
- I'm gonna go freeze this, let it set.
- Now we're gonna make the
gravy for the Loco Moco.
So we're gonna start by
melting some butter in a pot.
We're gonna saute the mushrooms.
- I have some washed cleaned rice here.
A cup of fresh mountain spring water.
- That's a lie.
- That's not a lie.
- I saw you get it from the sink.
- I never lie!
- You got it from the sink.
- No I didn't.
I'm gonna make some sushi rice.
- That looks familiar.
- Mmmm.
- Wait, what is the rice for?
- I don't know.
Maxley loved Ritz crackers,
so I'm gonna batter my chicken
nugget stars in Ritz cracker.
- Dude.
(crackers clinking against plastic)
- Put them all in...
(crackers grinding)
You want a fine dust.
- Now that my mushrooms
are nice and cooked,
we'll add the beef stock, and
then that corn starch slurry.
So it's very liquidy now,
but give it like five minutes
and you'll have your gravy glue.
- Blended Ritz crackers over batter.
I'll put a little paprika here,
but at the end we're gonna dust it
with fresh ketchup powder.
- Look at that. That's some good gravy.
Nice and thick and glossy.
We can let this go and cool.
The rice has been cooked,
so we'll add it to a...
(rice plops into glass bowl)
a bowl, and then add the seasonings:
rice vinegar, sesame oil, salt, and sugar,
and mix it all up so it'll
be nice, compact and sticky.
Put it on a sheet tray
and evenly distribute it.
- You can be messy. Just keep
it on your side, that's all.
- Yeah, but like come on.
There's like a few grains of rice.
- Messy's not bad...
but he's messier than me.
- Flatten it.
We're gonna freeze this,
cut it, and fry it.
- And we're gonna start my sushi balls.
- I knew you were gonna
mix them in. (chuckles)
- I'm dicing up, very
finely, some avocado.
So I'm gonna cut these
cucumbers into fine little stems
so they look like the tops of berries.
And this is something
I'm still working on,
but you can skin a cucumber
pressing down, small cuts.
You can rotate the cucumber
so you get your skin off.
- Why do you have to
complicate everything?
Let me like take out my
tweezers and be all nitpicky.
- So cucumbers looking pretty stemmy.
- I have puff pastry.
So I'm gonna start by rolling it out.
I'm gonna cut out shapes.
Kind of struggling here...
I'm having a little trouble
cutting out the stars.
Look at this star.
(audience laughs)
Like what? What is this?
But I did hear a great
tip on flowering the mold
so it just slides right out.
Oh, look at that! It worked! It worked!
- Tips for Owen.
That's perfect. You got it!
- Now we're gonna brush
this with egg wash.
This will be a good
binder for the Parmesan
that we're gonna sprinkle on top.
I'm gonna go bake 'em.
Hopefully the shape will hold
- For the last component
of the California roll,
imitation crab.
And I'm just gonna do a little test
because this is my first
time making California rolls.
But I'm gonna try to bind avocado
with the imitation crab
with a little mayo.
- Now that the rice has cooled and set,
I'm gonna be using these two shapes
to cut out the layers of the cake.
I'm like scared.
So I've never made a rice patty this big
and I'm definitely struggling
to get it inside the pot.
- No, put it flat on the cutting board.
Classic Owen. Just needing my help again.
This way. No, no. Flip it over right now.
- How's my hand supposed to flip that way?
He's always there for me when I need him.
No, go like...
- There, and then take the paper off.
- Oh, thank you.
- [H] All right.
- Gently slide it in away from you.
(triumphant music)
Yeah!
(H claps)
- If I lose because of the cake...
(Owen laughs)
I swear to God.
My California roll mixer is done
and I'm gonna start seasoning my rice.
(rice plops against glass and wood)
- Dude!
(H laughs)
- Rice vinegar, salt, sugar.
- I will say, this worries
me seeing him make rice.
Because, to be honest, the
best sushi rice I've ever had
is from H.
- Making sure every grain is coated.
It's a little too seasoned, but...
It's like too seasoned.
It's too much vinegar.
- That was not the rice
I was talking about.
- No. (chuckles)
I'm just not in my element.
This is like not my rice cooker, nor-
- Huh.
- the right amount I use.
Can I please borrow some of your rice?
- So you want to take some of my rice?
- Mhmm.
- I was a little taken aback
when H asked to use my rice
to make his rice better, but
since he lended me a hand
in getting the rice in the fryer,
I'm obviously gonna help him out.
Yeah. You got it.
- Okay, thank you. (laughs)
This is looking great.
We got that nice golden
crust on the outside.
So we're just gonna transfer it over
and let it drain and cool.
- So now we're gonna form our
yellow sushi ball berry thing.
To make it yellow, we're gonna
use yuzu or yellow tobiko.
So our base layer, you gotta
be very gentle with this stuff.
- I think H is taking a big
risk with the sushi balls.
He's covering it in fish eggs.
I don't know what nine
year old likes that.
- Next layer is rice.
A little bit of our filling,
a little bit more rice to seal that.
So you pull this all together,
and try to get all the air out,
and you're gonna twist
and form a sushi ball.
Unravel this puppy.
I'm gonna add little stems.
- That ain't it. That ain't it.
- It's cute!
- That is not a yellow berry.
- This is an interpretation. (laughs)
I think it looks more like a yellow brain.
Either way it doesn't look that great,
but when you put the little stem on top,
I think it looks cute.
- Now I'm gonna show you how
to make real yellow berries.
So we're gonna start by
cleaning up the pineapple.
So I have this ring mold
that kind of resembles like a berry shape.
Oh! Ha ha! That's pretty cool.
So I am making punctures in the pineapple
to put in the little airhead stems.
- My chicken has frozen.
Gonna punch 'em out
with these star shapes.
Flour, egg wash, Ritz cracker breadcrumb.
- All right, so now we
have our puff pastry stars.
These are great. Look at that.
Now we just gotta turn them red.
And so to do that, we
have even more cheese.
Mix that with some red food coloring,
and then we're just
gonna coat it, toss it,
and that's a red cheese star.
Look at that.
- That looks radioactive.
Why does it look like a
nuclear power plant? (laughs)
- He may think it's radioactive.
I think Maxley will think it
looks identical to the picture.
- Bang, fry.
(hot oil sizzling)
Dude, look at that.
That looks unreal.
- That's pretty cool.
- My final stage, I'm gonna
dust this... ketchup powder.
Bang! Red stars that aren't radioactive.
- Dude, that looks just as gnarly as this.
(H laughs)
- My banana bread cake is done.
So I'm just cutting off
the top to flatten it
and create my three
tiered banana bread cake.
- I'm gonna be shaving
off some vegetables.
Got a bunch of different colors here.
Yellow strips, purple cabbage, green...
We're gonna use his favorite vegetable:
good old broccoli.
- Look at that. That looks sick.
- That's a cake.
- I am not an expert at frosting.
- Your mom is a great baker, though.
- My mom is a great baker.
- [Producer] Do you know H's mom well?
- I do know H's mom quite well.
(H chuckles)
She would... (laughs)
(both laugh)
Hi, Susan!
- No, they get along well.
(producer laughs)
They get along really well.
So we're gonna start off with
our ocean mist right now.
I have a bunch of
delicious ingredients here.
All natural.
What's that over there?
- All right, hear me out.
Kids love all of this.
(H laughs)
We got ingredients for a
Mountain Dew Baja Blast.
And now to make this magical drink,
add some honey around the rim,
roll it in some pop rocks,
an even ratio of Mountain Dew and Sprite,
and then the rest will
be Frost Cool Gatorade.
And then this is blue and it's sugar,
so I'm gonna put it in
inside the cup as well.
There you have it! Blue misty drink.
- So to make this ocean
mist misty and oceany
I'm gonna spoon in a powder.
- My man, with your plate,
he's eating chicken nuggets,
a whole cake, sushi balls....
He's gonna be quite parched.
And does he want to, like,
take down a thick shake?
No. He is gonna want
some nice cool misty
Mountain Dew Baja Blast.
- You know...
- That's my thought process.
- You do you.
My thought process was
nailing each component.
I don't think that a nine
year old is gonna think
about the balance of an
entire composed dish.
- All right, drinks are done.
Let's play it up and present it.
- Yes, Chef.
- My burger patties shrunk significantly,
so I'm gonna have to basically
shrink everything else
to make sure it has that
tier layer for the cake.
- First thing I'm gonna deal with is
decorating my banana bread cake.
So I'm gonna first measure
some of these Twizzlers
to line up the tier cake.
Yours is a lot more difficult. (chuckles)
- The gravy glue seems to be working nice.
It's also gonna be very flavorful.
And now I'm just gonna cut
a mold for the chicken.
And the last part is just a fried egg.
Look at that! That's a savory cake.
- Do you think, when
Maxley tries your cake,
he's gonna think Loco Moco?
- I really hope so.
(both laugh)
- So now we're going
to decorate said cake.
It's the cake for the Pokemon God.
Realizing though that I need to decorate
a bit more than I thought
or else this cake looks pretty plain.
- We'll add the red stars...
So he has a few red stripes on there,
I'm gonna just try to make
a few red lines with ketchup
- Purely for spacing, I chose
this really big lazy Susan,
because this cake is what's-
- What's a lazy Susan?
- It's the term for
this. It's a lazy Susan.
- What?!
- Yeah.
- It's your mom's name.
- It is my mom's name! (laughs)
- My red stars on the plates.
My yellow berries,
and my wonderful ocean mist milkshake.
And I am done.
- All right, well let's
see what Maxley thinks.
- And may the best cook win.
("Brindisi" from La Traviata
by Giuseppe Verdi plays)
Overall, I'm super happy with
the entire dish as a whole.
I'm really stoked with
how the cake turned out.
I think you can clearly see each layer
and the different colors.
The red stars I think are identical.
They also taste great.
The blue drink I think is also super cool.
Give him that mist effect.
It's blue, it's sweet, it's sugar.
What more do you want?
The berries, it is just pineapple,
but I added the green airheads.
Hopefully he will be a fan of that.
I think it looks a lot like the picture.
I hope Maxley likes it too.
- I'm feeling pretty good about this dish.
Starting with the cake,
I think it looks great.
I think it looks like the picture,
even though it's not a perfect
oval with a hundred colors.
The yellow berries, I
think they look adorable,
and they honestly look like
something out of Pokemon.
He likes chicken cutlets;
I think chicken nuggets hit the spot.
Ocean mist tastes great.
I feel like every single kid in the world
loves vanilla milkshakes.
Hopefully Maxley enjoys
my plate more than Owen's,
and I can take home the prize.
- Bring on my dream Pokemon dish!
(playful music)
(cartoon flourish)
Oh, my God!
They actually went full out on this.
It was actually supposed
to be green, not purple.
- Maxley, I tried my best with the colors.
Just gimme a break.
- And they actually did the umbrella.
(Maxley claps)
I think I'll eat the stars.
That's chicken!
(Maxley bites into the nugget)
- I'm wondering now, what is the red?
Hmm! That actually does taste good.
(playful music continues)
I don't really like it...
- Oh, my God.
He didn't like the sushi balls.
- What are they?
- Just take a bite of the middle.
It's your favorite California roll!
- Wait a minute...
What is inside?
Let's try it.
It tastes like my dad's
coffee with frosting on it.
(Owen stifling laughter)
- Why is he drinking his
dad's coffee? (laughs)
- The cake itself is okay in the middle.
The colors actually
bring it a little bit up.
Overall, I think the drink
is what is keeping it up.
- I'm gonna lose.
(cartoon flourish)
- Holy smokes! I can't believe this.
It kind of looks very close to it.
How did they get the egg so small?
- He seems stoked.
- They kind of burnt it a little.
It tastes lemony.
It tastes okay.
(Maxley chewing the sugar stick)
The hard candy is really hard to bite in.
That's pop rocks! (chuckles)
I think we'll try the star.
It's hard... or kind of.
(Maxley chewing the puff star)
What is this?
Hey, it's cool and edible.
Hey, they actually do look like it.
- I think I'm definitely
getting more points on accuracy.
- I think I'll try this cake.
Oh, I know what this is.
The Loco Moco.
That's actually good.
That is chicken.
The red chicken was better.
(audience laughs)
- He's as smart as I thought! He's good.
- I knew it.
It was pineapple.
The green thing mixed
well with the pineapple.
Overall the cake was pretty
good, and also the pineapple.
Let's bring out the chefs!
(playful music)
- [Owen] What's up?
- (chuckles) What's up?
- [H] Hello, hello!
- Oh, hello!
- How are we doing?
- Good.
- All right, Maxley. Which
dish did you like more?
Dish one or dish two?
- Dish one.
(triumphant music)
(H cheers, Maxley laughs)
- I won!
- Here you go!
- Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
- Thank you for being on with me,
and also baking me the
greatest lunch ever.
- Aw, thank you. That was really sweet.
- It's the greatest
achievement of my entire life.
- Congrats, H Woo.
Maxley, I hope you enjoyed your food,
and I'll see you in fourth grade.
Do I get a consolation prize?
- Yeah, a hug.
- Aw, come here Maxley.
- Aww.
Can I get a hug?
- Yeah, sure.
- Thank you very much
for letting me, like,
eat what you made.
- Thank you.
- It's my honor.
- It is not your honor!
You get paid to do it.
(everyone laughs)
(playful music continues)
(music fades out)